Courtney wrote in saying what do you
think about zoos are they fun and
educational or terrible places for
animals I've never asked Pat about this
but being vegan I have a guess as to
what he would say I've talked about this
before
I hate zoos I do not go to zoos I think
that there are terrible places for
animals growing up in my home country of
Argentina I would go to the zoo very
often when visiting Argentina I would go
to the zoo in the capital city of Buenos
Aires I thought it was great I will no
longer go unfortunately that Zoo is
being shut down they are shutting the
whole thing down which I am glad about
I don't like zoos I think that they are
unethical it's it's just not a good
environment for animals the animals are
not treated particularly well it's not
you know the amount of space that
they're confined to is really a disaster
and we've heard so many stories zoos and
SeaWorld share a some overlap in terms
of the horrible things that go on I am
completely against zoos not a surprise I
am also completely against zoos I just I
take issue with this idea that you're
going to take a wild animal and confine
it to a certain amount of space as if
it's your property and some people you
know that extends for me in terms of
zoos in terms of animal agriculture we
especially shouldn't have the little
confinements that they have to live in
but also even if it's just a farm that's
open but fenced in I'm against that
because I don't consider animals to be
my property some people will take issue
with pet ownership even within the vegan
community I do have a cat but I like to
think that because it's an outdoor cat
she's able to go outside and you know to
spend all the time she wants and go
anywhere and then come back willingly
yeah so I'm able to rationalize let's
explore that a little bit the cat is
still although maybe not physically
imprisoned the cat is psychologically
captive in the sense that it has
identified that the inside of your house
is its source of sustenance and that is
where its litter boxes and blah blah
blah so I think that if you're going to
open up the door to any physical barrier
whatsoever is a form of captive animals
if the animal only knows that this is
where it gets its food and this is I
think that the physical barriers are
less relevant because
mentally it's still captive in the same
way see you see it as that I'm
brainwashing the cat where I see it as a
symbiotic relationship so I get the
companionship I get to pet the cat yeah
and in exchange she gets to come here
and eat but she also captures her own
food out in the wild too so she doesn't
need me to survive she just considers me
a friend yeah and that's why she comes
back well it's great that you've been
able to construct this story to feel
good about it all right Courtney so long
story short I'm against zoos and so is
pat on the bonus show today fantastic
bonus show but I won't tell you what's
on it because we're out of time david
pakman.com slash membership sign up
coupon code
I voted 17